all right so we were talking about the
browns when we dodged out big mike um
too soon to buy into a man i mean i
don't you know we don't get fooled again
you know buying into the browns that's a
tough division there they got what is it
uh
every team in that division
yeah three wins
you know um
three teams have three yeah three teams
have three wins and cincinnati's got his
first i'm sorry i misspoke there but
that's a tough division but they look
pretty good what do you think of the
brown so far
oh it's an extremely tough division i
think that you can look at and see
positive you see signs of growth nobody
expected that they were going to
overtake baltimore this year or that
they're going to overtake uh pittsburgh
now that pittsburgh is back big ben is
healthy and everything like that but
they're competitive um you know they're
they're exciting and so i think yeah you
can buy into them as a team that's
growing maybe they're a couple years off
but still just know that okay growing
pains are still going to happen
throughout the rest of the season
yeah mike i want to look uh look at the
flip side and i i put uh on my list
today of the cowboys let's just get to
them right now
and i raised the question
to myself is mike mccarthy is that is he
gonna be a one-and-done
dallas you know look at them at one and
three they look like they're just like a
big mess
what's your assessment of dallas
um i mean i'm obviously disappointed in
because i felt like okay this is the guy
that dak prescott needs to help him go
to the next level i figured that okay
mike mccarthy has been in the lab for
this whole time that he was out of work
working with his coaching staff and
figuring out how they wanted to do
things they were studying game film
every single week and figuring it out
and he assembles this staff
and this is what they have to show for
this still looks like the cowboys of old
you know lots of penalties
lots of turnovers they lead the league
in turnovers uh six lost fumbles three
interceptions their defense uh can't
stop anybody all those names that
they've got assembled there they're not
gelling and so you wonder okay they
didn't have an off season program they
didn't have preseason so we should give
them a little bit of grace right there
but still i expected much better from
this cowboys team
yeah i mean
that is it a lack of discipline is it
the players especially on defense the
players still adjusting to the scheme
i mean like that's just
it would seem like they got too much
talent to be performing this poorly i
mean like they're they're challenging
records for how poorest their defense is
no exactly i mean they gave up 307
rushing yards and three touchdowns
yesterday on 40 carries that doesn't
happen ever i mean not even you know the
worst defense is the lions from the 016
year you know that doesn't happen um i
think that it's a bit i mean some of
those guys you got there have been out
of football for a little bit some of
these guys they haven't played with each
other and again no otas
no normal training camp no preseason to
kind of get in sync with mike nolan in
this defense now could they wind up i
mean could he wind up being the
sacrificial lamb uh that's possible i
think mike mccarthy will get a little
bit of time but i still think they've
got to add some help onto their back end
there eric reid is sitting out there um
you know they definitely need help with
there but they've got to get some
cohesion and we're just not seeing that
because the defensive line a defense of
front seven works together like a fist
all of those guys have to be doing their
jobs at the same time for them to have
success and they're just not having it
right now
you know mike uh mike jones by the way
three mikes here um but we've been
paying we've been making a lot of fun of
the atlanta atlanta falcons now i'm
having a great time falcons blowing
leads
uh in at least two games and i don't
even know if they had a lead against
seattle they had they scored a bunch of
points maybe they had a big lead in that
game too i don't think so
but a team that's that that has gotten
off the hook here
is the detroit lions
they could they get leads all the time
they were up 14 zip yesterday
they blow that game they were up early
first game in the season they blow that
one and this is the year that matt
patricia was told oh wait michael oh no
michael no we gotta we gotta get it
right michael hold on hold on six
straight games six yeah in which they'll
last ten or more points that's the
longest stricken in nfl history they've
lost six straight games when they were
led by ten continue just wanted to get
that out there i'm saying and this year
this year for sure okay every game
they've had leads and they've blown them
but this is the year that matt patricia
was supposed to be you know proving
himself to the organization
you think he'll make it through the
season
um that's a good question i wouldn't be
surprised if he does not um when you
look at this i don't see accountability
i mean even yesterday his explanation
saying look when i took over this team
and needed a lot of work and so that's
what we're trying to do right now that
team had won three of the last four
seasons they made the playoffs twice
under jim caldwell and they thought that
he could elevate them instead he's run
him into the ground they lost 11
straight last year um after starting the
year 2-0 i think it was like they won
one like one out of 13 the next 13 games
um this team is not progressing this guy
was supposed to bring in the patriot way
he's gotten patriots players and signed
them and everything like that but it has
not paid off you don't see excellence
out of you know any high standard of
play out of either side of the ball um
you've got a talented quarterback you're
wasting him
i don't see how matt patricia comes back
for another season and this thing could
get ugly enough that i don't see how he
makes it through the rest of the year
well then it's not just matt patricia
it's bob quinn you know who made the
decision to go from jim caldwell uh to
matt patricia and what's disappointing
mike's what's the most disappointing
thing is the the comment the answer that
you talked about mike jones because he
was asked matt patricia was you know why
should people believe that you're still
the right coach to turn this thing
around
now
that is a tough question a legitimate
question and a fair question but a tough
question and
he needed to answer it better than he
did he needed to answer it and not come
off as though
he's suggesting what the facts you know
would completely uh go against
i mean has he won nine games in the year
since they fired jim caldwell off a nine
and seven season and was worse to me
than losing a bunch of games
is losing respect and i just wonder yes
how that plays
around the league but even in his own
locker room
when you're perceived as not saying hey
it starts with me it starts with me it
ends with me
you know my record you know as as part
as my mentor's mentor said you are what
your record says you are my record is
not good something that would just
recognize that that that you're looking
inwardly as opposed to well there was a
lot of work to do when i got here and
well clearly you're not the guy for the
job
you know what i mean i just that's the
part that worries me about about matt
patricia
uh is that it's that's just not a way
you want to uh
conduct yourself am i making sense
no absolutely you would not want your
your left tackle to say hey man well i
got a trash guard next to me and the
tight end doesn't hit its blocks or
anything like that no you say coach i've
got to do better so he should say well i
know that i'm putting everything i can
into this i know that i've got my
players best interests at heart and we
are in this together don't go talk about
somebody who is before you if you have
not topped them you know say that you
know caldwell had gone 0-16 for two
straight years and you won two games
then then maybe you could say hey we've
got a young roster we're turning it over
fitting it to our image but don't make
it sound like you inherited something so
bad when you have not achieved anything
close to the standard that was already
set
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports